my name is Brian Daugherty on the senior
editor recent magazine and the author of
the new book Ron Paul's revolution the
man and the movement he inspired
I say this with amazement but it's
becoming more and more clear that we
live in the age of Ron Paul a lot of
people don't take Ron Paul seriously as
a politician they look at his you know
three-decade career in Congress and say
what does this guy ever done I mean
practically no Billy's ever introduced
has even gotten out of committee well
that's not the kind of legislature Ron
Paul is I mean he's not there to do what
all of his colleagues want to do which
is basically use the machine of
government to sort of funnel other
people's money to whatever they think is
important but as a political figure Ron
Paul has been remarkably successful a
set of ideas that he was almost alone in
believing in a set of ideas that you
could you know never gather more than 40
people in any one place to stand up for
have now become so popular that he is
drawing crowds of 7,000 he is able to
get 35 million dollars two times in a
row to support his presidential campaign
his fans understand that what Ron Paul
is out to do is not just to win an
election this is not to say that Oh Ron
Paul isn't running to win or Ron Paul
doesn't want to win I'm quite convinced
that Ron Paul would be very happy to win
but unlike other candidates Ron Paul can
succeed even if he doesn't win he's
going to continue to rack up delegates
he's pursued this rather curious
strategy of aiming his campaigns
attention at the caucus states where the
straw poll results that we all here on
the election day are actually not
meaningful at all in how delegates are
allocated and by doing this he ended up
winning essentially states like Iowa in
Minnesota even though people didn't
realize he had won them at the time but
even if Ron Paul get shut out at the
Republican convention in Tampa in August
even if you know they don't let him have
a prominent speaking gig even if they
try to shut the door in his face just
like they did in 2008 which led Ron Paul
to run his own counter convention which
drew 13,000 people across town in
Minneapolis even if they do this the the
injection of Ron Paul ISM in the
Republican Party through the 2012
campaign is not going to die that does
not mean
that ron paul is creating some sort of
cult of personality uniquely among
politicians ron paul gets his fans
reading ron paul writes serious books of
political thought in political
philosophy and they become bestsellers
those books always have bibliographies
Ron Paul is always talking in his public
speeches about the thinkers who
influenced him whether it be the
Austrian economist Ludwig von Mises or
the 19th century French liberal Frederic
Bastiat and that's also why the Ron Paul
movement is going to have legs even when
Ron Paul is not on the political scene
anymore this is his last run for
president he's not going to be in
Congress anymore after this year he is
leaving in his wake a set of
institutions and a set of hundreds of
thousands of dedicated energized
intelligent youngsters who
unquestionably are going to shape
American politics moving down the line
even when Ron Paul is no longer there
leading the charge I think the most
meaningful historical analogy for the
role that Ron Paul and the Ron Paul
movement is going to play in the
Republican Party but now and in the
future is Barry Goldwater back in
nineteen sixty when he represented this
strongly anti-government force that was
driving the establishment crazy that was
overwhelmingly young overwhelmingly
energetic and that filled the party of
the degree that the party had to become
more respectful of his attitudes in the
future and then what you saw sixteen
years down the line was Ronald Reagan a
guy who had been out on the stump for
Barry Goldwater in 1964 is a
presidential candidate and I think
you're going to see that same pattern of
unfold for the Ron Paul people I would
remind you that extremism in the defense
of Liberty is no vice
it's about steering this country's
philosophy of government in the future
and on that level I think it's
undeniable that Ron Paul and his
campaigns and his movement have been an
enormous success what happens if my
concerns are completely unfounded
nothing but what happens if my concerns
are justified and ignored nothing good
and I yield back the balance of my time